l'institution de la presse française le
journal le monde inauguré hier après
midi sa nouvelle imprimerie la plus
moderne d'europe qui va lui permettre
suprême fantaisie au monde de publier
des suppléments en couleur pour fêter
cet événement qui s'accompagnent de très
bons résultats financiers et bien le
journal avait invité ses lecteurs qui
représente 11 % des actionnaires et qui
sont très impliqués dans la marche de
leur quotidien préféré
reportage de thierry calmette et patrig
vitesse maximum pour un quotidien qui
incite à la réflexion telle pourrait
être la devise de l'imprimerie du
journal le monde à ivry y préparer dans
ce nouveau coeur du journal ambiance
loft ateliers pour les lecteurs car si
d'autres journaux tirent leur force d'un
groupe multimédia le monde lui s'appuie
sur ses rédacteurs et ses lecteurs
invités pour la visite des rotatives qui
mettront enfin de la couleur dans le
monde
ce qui ne surprend pas les plus vieux
lecteurs ceux de 1944 45
voilà il fallait vraiment avoir bien
envie de lire c'est vrai que la
concurrence n'était pas très forte sur
la qualité l'intérêt international
mondial du journal et puis très vite
aussi par rapport au temps d'avant
guerre se son indépendance indépendance
à condition de résister à la concurrence
grâce à ces rotatif qui dès septembre
tourneront en quadrichromie le monde va
s'égayer petit à petit mais
l'investissement de 350 millions de
francs à ivry montre la volonté de
rajeunissement du journal réclamée par
tous les nouveaux abonnés
je serai très favorable à l'introduction
des poteaux jeu constamment un peu dans
le monde
je ne gêne beaucoup les dessins de
plantu de sergei
vous pouvez pas illustré bien ça le rend
moins austère mais ce qu'il manque c'est
la couleur
je n'irai pas à dire que j'ai une
passion pour le monde dont il fait
partie de ma journée en fait je ne
passerai pas une soirée tangible le
monde et surtout les rubriques
d'international dire que le nouveau
monde arrive serait exagéré ici
évolution lente mais jamais de
révolution tout juste un brin de fierté
dans l' il lorsqu'on vous dit que cette
imprimerie la plus moderne de france
pour une fois pas de séparation entre le
fait et le commentaire